charlie morton the veteran right-hander
37 years old four and two
with a 4-26 era he is making his 12th
start this year
no score just underway top of the first
inning dodgers threatening
chris taylor batting cleanup today
twice this week chris taylor has come up
with the bases loaded
and twice this week has unloaded the
bases with doubles
snap throw back to first and it gets
over freeman
that'll allow bellinger to take second
base
bets will come home and the game's first
run belongs to the dodgers
morton a long look into veteran catcher
kevin smith
one two on the way clocked out towards
dansby leaps up into the air brings it
down
and that's out number two
that looks like he was hit just
underneath the label he didn't quite get
a big
pop on it it'll bring matt beatty up to
the plate if you can find a way to get
through the top of the first inning
giving up just the one run
you'll feel like you dodged a bullet
here's the 1-0 on the way to beatty
popped up left side riley right back to
the bag at third now in foul ground
makes the catch and that's out number
three unfortunately morton gives up just
the one run
one run no hits two errors clayton
kershaw on the mound
seven and four with a 3 33 era
the 33 year old left-hander making his
13th start
albie's at 256. nine homers
34 runs batted in sign down and the wind
in the pitch
breaking ball swung on and missed strike
three kershaw got him with a slider
three up three down for the braves in
the first we go to the second
at truest park in atlantis the dodgers
one braves nothing
two down down for austin barnes ozzy
shifting to the left side of the infield
freddie home alone on the right side
one ball and two strikes from the pitch
on the way from charlie
not a thing wrong with that fastball
called third strike
and a one two three inning for charlie
morton no runs hits or errors none left
we had to the bottom of the second
with the dodgers leading the braves one
to nothing swanson is 48 for
203 on the season
so you go fastball fastball and then
kershaw goes down to 75
on the curveball for the strikeout first
shot 4 for 16
so far this year here's the one two on
the way from morton
and that's in for a call third strike
drop the curve ball in
two down bases empty for justin turner
who reached on the
fielding error by austin reilly in the
first inning one-nothing dodgers top of
the third
base is empty two balls two strikes two
outs pitch on the way
got him good fastball
charlie morton really looking good after
that throwing air in the first inning
he's now retired eight in a row no runs
hits or errors none left we had to the
bottom of the third inning with the
dodgers on top of the braves one to
nothing
braves have runners at first and second
with two down for freddy freeman
pitch on the way that's clocked in the
air out to center field that'll drop for
a base in
running third coming to the plate
horadia the throw from bellingers up the
line
and a tie ball game freddie down to
second acuna over to third
1-1 here in the third inning and now
ozzie takes
his crack at kershaw another one two on
the way
hit hard down the left field line out
there towards the corner down for a base
hit
all the way to the wall acuna will score
freeman touches the plate
an rbi double out of ozzie albee's
gives the braves a 3-1 lead here in the
third dansby struck out back in the
second inning so this is a second look
at clayton kershaw
dansby is the eighth brave to the plate
here at the bottom of the third inning
braves on top three to one
runners are the quarters two one on the
way hit hard out to the gap
that'll lay down for a base hit and roll
all the way to the warning track
scoring with eases ozzy here comes riley
around third he will score
dansby swanson with a two rbi double
the braves have high fived the dodgers
here in the bottom of the third and this
place
is pulsing with energy a-ray andreanza
comes up for the second time tonight
grounded to second baseman chris taylor
in the shift
in the second in it there's the o2
andreyanza waves and strikes out and
kershaw faces nine
five come in to score two on and nobody
out for matt beatty
freeman holding taylor taylor gets into
his lead near the cut of the grass and
baby lines one into left center field a
base hit that's going to get bellinger
in
taylor will hold it second and the
dodgers get another run back it's five
to two on an rbi single by matt beatty
warden's going to face mckinstry who's
hitting
1 000 in his career
with bases loaded only two at mats but
two hits
at four rbis back up the middle
chance for two step on the back swanson
throw to first in time
the braves will concede the run it's the
third dodger run of the game
the second of this fourth inning but
they'll take the two outs no rbi for
mckinstry barnes important to get on
with kershaw on deck
trying to get on the other side of that
for the following minute
ground ball left side backhanded by
swansea
loads up throws to first it is off the
mark and safe at first as barnes and he
comes up limping
scoring from third on the play is baity
it's five to four
and barnes is really limping as he comes
back to the first base bang
four errors in the first two games of
this set riley had one in the first
this scored a run the pick off attempt
allowed betts to come home
[Applause]
this swanson error in the fourth inning
allowed a run to score as well
that's hit by a pitch in the first
scorer he's grounded out twice since he
looks at a breaking ball hits it down to
third and it's right through the wickets
of austin riley
and this guy taylor loves that first
pitch oh
two on the way got him swinging strike
three 97 mile an hour fastball
and that was right on by the swinging
bat of chris taylor
no runs no hits one error
two left and we'll stretch him out el
monte a switch hitter a good guy to have
in this spot he turns around to bat
left-handed against china
2-1 that's it high in the air to deep
right field
back there towards the pole heading for
the chop house
that's a home run abraham almante with a
skyscraper to right field
his first and the braves head on to the
lead it's six to four
so they're loaded up full of braves for
airy andreanza
pitched to adrianza ground ball right to
try it underhand toss to first only
suspense
is ended quickly one run on the solo
home run by abraham almante the braves
leave them loaded will go to the eighth
two down in the ninth braves need one
more out to put this one in the win
column
a 6-4 lead here late here's justin
turner
one-two pitch got him looking strike
three and the series has even won a
piece